so guys we all have our roles in the
family whether it's the peacemaker the
golden child the rebel you know the the
black sheep curious what your roles were
growing up I have always been the
peacemaker in my family yeah so i have
i've had to fly in and sit the family
dad and say okay let's hear from this
side now this i gets us to act aside
gets a sweet so I've always been that
the one in the middle so sort of um cute
yeah keeping peace um it's interesting i
I'm my dad had a first marriage and he
had two two daughters from that and then
I'm my mother's only child and in a
second marriage so I I was always the
baby of the family and I play this weird
girl were like with my parents it was
comfortable I wouldn't say I wouldn't
say very much because I think we always
had this weird knowledge of what the
other one was thinking about them my
sisters would come into the situation I
would just immediately be like silent
and like not know what to say and just
like sit in the corner and just did you
know I thought sounds bad I love them
like we you know we get along really
well and you're really interesting when
I was one-on-one with my sisters it was
like amazing it was beautiful i'm like
they were like half-brother half-sister
half best friend like it was perfect but
for some reason when everyone got in the
room together i just too was terrified
like everybody else was taking up the
room yeah see you're just like watching
yeah i was watching and taking notes
didn't clearly just kidding well the
tagline or one of the tag lines for cold
turkey is something like despite our
best efforts we eventually turn into our
parents and you know in this day of you
know new age and self-help books and
everybody's sort of working on their
inner selves how does that still happen
pretty much it you know I think we've
all been there and then we catch
ourselves like oh my gosh that's what
so-and-so used to say yeah I mean self
helps okay but I think biology is
apoorva hurtful I don't know I mean you
your I think a your product of the
situation once you were raised but your
its brain chemistry like
you really do you your brain is this
incredible combination of your two
parents and you can't avoid that you
can't fake that I can't really undo
keepall years and years of I mean I find
my I'm a parrot now and I find myself I
said to my daughter the other day you
know I don't want you up on the roof
because I don't feel like spending the
day in emergency room so it's like not
only am I not saying I'm worried about
your safety it's really about I don't
want to waste my time in the emergency
room I remember with my mom when I was
little I was like that's so selfish of
you you don't want to spend the day in
the emergency room what about me I'd
like to be on the roof but now it's like
flipped and I understand it and it's it
is a long you know we don't know how
many trips you've had to the emergency
it's a long day and it's inconvenient so
I find myself saying the same days at my
mom said right were you more cognizant
with this project of like you know
catching yourselves and just kind of
like oh wow this really does happen like
despite our best efforts to kind of just
be the person we want to be it all moves
well one thing that I really liked about
this script and I don't want to give
away the ending but I really like the
end because this family they're flawed
they know they're flawed but they say
you know that's who we are and we can't
change and it's interesting cuz you're
cute when you're watching you're
thinking if you know you're so flawed
and it's what you're doing is wrong I
feel like you could change too but
there's something comfortable about
having people around you that are
exactly the same that are all saying why
can't change either so they all sit in a
little group and sit around say we can't
change as who we are take it or leave it
looks like really so I like that in a
script that I I kind of like that about
people cuz they are you know at the end
of the day you are who you are you
haven't you some people can change it
takes a lot if you want to change but
most people don't takes a big Fork
stabbing
yeah thanksgiving dinner to change yeah
well I think there's that rule too that
if one person within the group changes
then it forces others right and so they
try to keep depends me yeah yeah your
dad then everyone goes along but you
know sure matter yeah so with the
Thanksgiving holiday coming up and if a
family member or family together was to
go see the film or watch it at home what
do you want them to take away about
family dynamics coming to peace with who
you are or you know you can't you can't
choose your family so what what message
do you want them to come away with I
mean honestly it's the family's all you
got and I you know in in some ways that
that's difficult to deal with and
complicated but in some ways it's great
like it doesn't matter you know at the
end of the day like you know what job
you have with money you have like what
all this stuff doesn't matter like you
have to tell your family that you love
them and they have to tell you that they
love you and it sounds stupid and Pat
and Trey and ridiculous but it's the
point the friggin movie is that they
these people are unable to talk to one
another and they exist on this you know
they'll talk about a play or about a you
know foreign policy or you know what
would what wine one drinks but they're
unable to say they love each other so
that's the point of the movie and you
know the whole point is they at the end
they have to write anything for you
Cheryl I mean is there is there
something that you want people to take
away when they suppose someone went on
their own de theatre by themselves maybe
to get escape the family dinner yeah
what would you want them to take away um
well to be a little more shallow let's
just want them to be entertained you
know it is in a perfect world they'd
come away going wow my family my family
is not so bad compared to them so and so
just that sort of escape you know you go
to the movies and you watch somebody
else's life for an hour and a half and
you're like that was great and and it
like will says you know you hope that
they come with you hope people come out
thinking I'm thankful for what I have
and I gotta love my family regardless
but but it I really hope they come out
going what we're not as red ism
syclogic a reality show where you're
like that at least for not then yeah so
that's what I hope for the world when
you were writing the script did you have
people in mind I mean you have also
peter bogdanovich with the project I
mean did you have specific people did
you know Cheryl was going to be again
because it was so personal I just had
myself and my family in mind like I
wasn't I wasn't projecting anyone but
but them onto it but that's what's fun
about it is that you i have no I believe
me three years ago I did not know that
I'd be sitting in a chair next to Cheryl
Hines talking about a movie called cold
turkey where she puts my mother like you
know that's what's great is that I just
wrote it in a room to cheat on my
friggin iphone like I didn't care but
people like the script and so here we
are and how did you get it into the
appropriate hands can you Tom really
really good casting director name is
Paul Rudd II knew all these agents and
you all these managers knew Larry new
fad Larry David Larry yeah yeah yeah and
and was all through him I don't know
anyone I'm you know I'm some guy in a
basement scribbling away about my life
and he just had all these connections
and all these all these folks came in
and read and met and and I was it so
were there times within that three years
that it looked like it wasn't going to
happen oh it's funny oh of course I mean
the thing got pushed 17 times and fell
apart and 18 times and all that but
honestly it happened pretty quick I
wrote it in early 2011 and we shot in
early 2012 and we're sitting here and
you know mid to late 2013 which is is
quick for a movie that is great thanks
guys thank you yeah